What lies beyond the Star
Wars galaxy? Nobody knows
for sure — but Ahsoka might be about to show us.
Ahsoka's fifth episode is quite the journey,
and it ends with the beginning of an even
bigger one. After being knocked into the
sea by Baylan Skoll at the end of Episode 4,
Ahsoka Tano finds herself in a mysterious
Force realm, where she comes face-to-face
with her old master, Anakin Skywalker. As Hera
Syndulla searches the planet Seatos for her,
Ahsoka revisits her tragic life story
through a series of Clone Wars flashbacks.
"I'm teaching you how to lead, how to survive.
And to do that, you're going to have to fight."
Anakin pushes Ahsoka to her limits in the World
Between Worlds and even attacks her outright,
but it seems that his aggression is all a kind
of game — a way to help his old padawan find some
peace within herself. And sure enough, Ahsoka
awakens from the ordeal with a powerful aura of
serenity. She then quickly divines a way to pursue
Morgan Elsbeth, Sabine Wren, and the others, even
without a star map. This is because Seatos is home
to a herd of purrgil, the hyperspace-traveling
space whales that took Ezra Bridger and Grand
Admiral Thrawn away in Star Wars Rebels.
At the end of Ahsoka Episode 5, Ahsoka uses the
Force to convince a purrgil through the Force
to allow her and Huyang to dock their
ship in its mouth. Tucked away inside,
they set off through hyperspace — and we already
have some clues as to where they might be going.
As Ahsoka herself acknowledges to Huyang, she
has no idea whether or not the purrgil will
actually take them to Sabine, Ezra, and Thrawn.
Because there are only three episodes left,
the writers don't have much time
to play around in other places,
but journeying through hyperspace isn't as
simple as hopping from point A to point B.
Prior to Ahsoka, many believed that Thrawn
was simply hiding in some far corner of the
Unknown Regions, an uncharted sector of
the existing Star Wars galaxy. Notably,
the ancient Sith planet of Exegol is located in
the Unknown Regions, along with the remnants of
the Empire that would later become the Final
Order. If Ahsoka has to travel through that
region of space on the way to Thrawn's galaxy, we
could get a glimpse of what's been going on there.
The Mandalorian Season 3 already established
that the Shadow Council of the Imperial Remnant
is waiting for Thrawn's return, hiding in the
Unknown Regions until someone can bring him back.
The Unknown Regions have barely been explored
in canonical Star Wars stories, which is fitting
given that they remain uncharted in-universe.
We know that Thrawn's species, the Chiss,
also hails from the area, and that it's quite
different from most known sectors of the galaxy.
But while the Unknown Regions are mysterious, even
less is known about what lies beyond them. And
Ahsoka's journey beyond the confines of the galaxy
opens up a number of exciting opportunities.
In canon, Ahsoka is the first major Star Wars
story to voyage beyond the galaxy. However,
the non-canon "Legends" timeline established
some details of what lies beyond the Outer
Rim. Most famously, the Yuuzhan Vong
invaded from a neighboring galaxy in
the EU's New Jedi Order laying waste to
beloved characters and whole planets.
The Yuuzhan Vong were divisive at the time because
they felt like such an intense departure from the
usual tone and style of Star Wars, but that
doesn't mean we won't see some influence in
whatever Ahsoka finds out there. It's also worth
noting that the canon Thrawn novels feature a
race similar to the Yuuzhan Vong called the
Grysk. They're not quite as horrifying or
dangerous as the classic "Legends" villains, and
they live in the Unknown Regions, not a separate
galaxy. But there's a definite possibility that
Thrawn's presence in Ahsoka could lead to a new
version of the Yuuzhan Vong storyline,
one that places the Grysk in their stead.
The implications that Ahsoka's story holds
for the greater Star Wars franchise are even
more fascinating. Disney can't stay in
the Skywalker Saga forever. Eventually,
new stories will have to be told, and many of
them are likely to be completely divorced from the
existing Star Wars narrative. After all, that's
how you bring in new fans and keep the story going
for younger generations. Because there's already
so much diversity in the main Star Wars galaxy,
a new one might not sound like a huge deal.
But that's a galaxy with no Jedi; with no Sith,
Republic, or Empire. It's a huge pool of
possibilities just waiting to be tapped.
"You've taken your first
step into a larger world."
All in all, Ahsoka's journey into the great beyond
could be the start of big
new things for Star Wars.